kourtney kardashian is white hot in  miami  the 38 year old reality star jetted off  to miami beach for a getaway with family  and friends  after cheering on sister chloe's man  tristan thompson  and the cleveland cavaliers at nba  finals game four  in ohio on friday the mother of three  flaunted her rockin bod on the beach in  a revealing white bathing suit  showing off her lean legs and toned  assets  she paired the beachy ensemble with tiny  black sunnies  and gold jewelry so chic and  so stylish court's newly single bestie  larsa pippin  also came along for the vacay  one person missing from the sunshine  courtney's rumored bow  jonas benjamin